Yes. And and we learnt quickly
and it was also important for us to
have times to be together as women.
For instance i'm part of a women's support
group which has been going for seven
years and it's been put important
for us to get together
and to talk about our own experiences
and to reflect and to really encourage
and challenge each other to take
steps and be brave and despair gap.
And it's been important for
the men also to get together
and to explore what have to be in the
limitations of growing up in the society on
them as men and what did they need to
do to open up their other aspects.
So at times we worked separately
and then came back together much
stronger both much stronger
and were able to face each other
and times work on forgiveness.
Yeah that was important. Problems working.
It's not a problem with people
who accept the necessity for it.
I mean this times when when it might
have been perceived as a threat.
But it's it seems a lot more can
happen by working together.
Initially separately and then coming
back together and meeting is as equals.
Rather than sort of hammering
it out on an individual basis.
Somehow that's a slower path here so
the women's movement has been a really
important strand.
I think in the growing and changing
and bringing aquarius to through it.
Yes.
I am in the area is seeing. Yeah.
Alan andresen.
The deferred.
But very much part of the the aquarius
generation i suppose i was a radical young
senior tutor in psychology in the
car uni at the time of the festival
and it was all
that stuff was in the air about about leaving
the cities about making our own world
instead of the one that was producing the
vietnam war and the oil crisis and the
and what we thought was the you know
just the the decline in the whole
quality of life and the absence
of any kind of spiritual
or magic dimension in life in the
lives of our parents i suppose. And.
After the queries. First of
all that it became obvious
that some people were actually leaving the
cities leaving the universities going up
to leave in the way that we were
all starting to talk about.
And the beginning of 1975 and.
I already knew some some friends who are
already come up to to live in a minute
left their jobs and so i got to be
friends got to be part of a group.
Who were interested in buying
a huge area of land and.
A little bit west of nimbin where we
could have a virtually self-sufficient.
Place almost a self-sufficient town
and eventually about 25
shareholders 25. Groups.
Some a couple summer single people.
Both 65000 acres of land out on the head
of the clarence river a couple of hours
west of newman. Yeah carol when you was.
It's really a wilderness it's
the headwaters of the clarence
and the cataract rivers.
So it's completely mountainous with some
tiny little bits of flatland perfectly
suited to to a commune for lots of people
to live on because it's magic country.
It's miles of literally mars of these rivers
because they snake around all the all
the mountains and magic mushrooms
grew there in profusion. And.
You couldn't farm it very much.
So it looked like a lot of hard work and
it was just really interesting country.
It was.
Not hundreds of miles away but only any
sort of 70 kilometres away from the coast.
And we thought that. What we do is go and
move up there and have a be able to.
To make a truly self-sufficient sort of
lifestyle with some of the high tech new
age.
Things like fish farming
in organic agriculture
that were being studied
in the in the new age.
Institutions in america.
We were at a mixed group.
Basically the group started with a group
called design farm from western australia
which was a core group of a couple of
architects in a couple of engineers who
tended for did to build
and design how mining towns in western
australia including putting in the water
supply and the electricity supply
power supply and roads and all
that sort of thing
and they found they work out to a lot of
kind of people who would like to work for
six or nine months intensively
but weren't 9 to 5.
So the people so that was a group
got together together with them.
They were from western australia
and the other half of the group came
from sydney where i'm expansive.
I was an academic there
were some musicians.
But just generally people who are interested
in creating our own lifestyle as a
person and you know living the way
that we were we were thinking challenging
the existing ideas of family
and economy
and the whole business of having an older
generation who were conscripting us to go
to war was we didn't believe in against.
You know the threat of so-called threat
of communism when we are self taught
that we need a lot more communality
in our lives and a lot more sharing
and a lot less and just
working to increase money
and we already had plenty. And i remember.
Just before we we came up to
see for we left the city.
We had a draft dodgers.
Sort of organization going
that we had hired people who'd already
been conscripted in the lottery.
And we brought you have to think as a russian
poet out to speak at new south wales
university which was a real.
Really flying in the face of a government
who was saying the conscripting us to to
fight. You know
that the communist system in
in latin south east asia.
Was based on all the new age principles.
You know ideas from living community and
nonviolently as the american indians did.
Ideas from the eastern religions
which we're starting to.
To embrace into. And the stand
and follow at that time. Lot of.
Ideas about having magic as well as the
spiritual dimension their lives from from
psychoactive psychedelic
drugs. But very much. I think.
Very much. It was just an adventure.
Very much life in the city was was quite
comfortable the country was wealthy.
It was easy to get scholarships
to go to university.
It was easier to be paid to do
research on social sciences
and how the family was breaking
down and hand you into personal
and family structures and
economic structures were needed.
And we just saw the opportunity to go out
and start doing instead
of just talking about it.
I member the couple of years before i left
i organised a course called a family in
the modern world in the behavioral
sciences school with contributions from
sociologists and psychologists and.
And through policies and after
having all sorts of people speak in
that course including people who had
come up and lived near me and already.
It was just time for any of us who
could to go up and actually do it
and not just talk about
and theorise about it.
Well in the early days even in the
early years. It was wonderful.
It was a it was a celebration
it was an adventure.
It was found it was very creative.
We are abuzz with talk about how
to build times and dodecahedron as
and how to put on water supplies from
hydraulic rams which didnt need any
electricity and all sorts of alternate
ways of refrigeration and fish farming
and agriculture that didnt need
chemicals and didn't abuse animals
and new forms of relationships and looking
after children and our own music and.
Just really all facets of
life. It was fascinating.
It was energetic it was
very colourful. Where you.
We wouldn't touch alcohol because
that was a the drug of the older generation
we smoke a lot of dope in a very
celebrate tree sort of.
Happy way rather than trying to
wipe ourselves out in any sense
that was really the last thing that
any of us would would want to do at
that stage because life was so
full of possibilities and houses
and dams to be built in water supplies
to be put on and new ways of living
and thinking to be found a new religion to
explore new aspects of the the internal
world through through
psychedelics and so on.
And i remember saturday mornings in the
promenade mornings where everyone would
come from there. From their week of.
Trying to get their new life style going
to to wear their colors and parade up
and down and talk to one another in the
shannon market and a couple of the was
that was the first market and
that was the monthly get together
with people from other villages
and people too far away to see
in the main on saturday morning.
And the best thing about the shannon market
was coffee because we don't we're all.
Reasonably city folks and.
That was probably a really
important thing in our lives.
The car in your experiment was.
Was a bit different to the women
one in that it was so isolated
and such a vast area and it really needed.
Probably a dozen people
or families to be there at once in order
to get such a big place going to do
something about the rivers far
as supplying regular water and.
Accommodation and we would
only go to town once a week
and the difficulty was carolinians
that we somehow just didn't get
that many people coming at once.
That was the only downside otherwise it was
it was quite wonderful to be a long way
away from home in. And in a very special
and vast place.
They didn't they didn't because.
I think mainly because not all 20
shareholders came over and made it go
and we would have needed that many almost
that many to to do the sorts
of projects that we wanted to
and we needed everybody to
bring all of the capital
and all of the time to the place and
get it going and when we came to carry
when you're in
when we bought it it looked like the quality
of life in the cities was declining
faily rapidly there was also an oil
crisis on where for some reason the opec
countries cut their supplies
because they thought
that this their supply of oil
was quite finite and limited.
And now they don't think that anymore
so they produce more but at that time.
There was some urgency in
finding alternate ways of life
that didn't depend on fossil
fuels and limited resources.
But about concurrently with
1975 76 when we went up there.
The oil crisis sort of
passed the past over
and things in the cities started
to get gradually better.
And somehow not enough people
were really willing to to sell up
and bring all their time and
all their resources to go.
We need to make it to make it work and i
think it was such an ambitious project
that it needed all that time and energy
and money to to make a go of it so it
turned out rather than be a real distant
retreat.
And at one stage we had plans of turning
it over to the national parks association
to make a national park of the whole
thing. And it's pretty much that now.
We're aiming for a real self-sufficiency
we're aiming for a place which really
could take care
and be a complete country almost
a self-sufficient country.
For and for a group of people.
And we had the idea we had in mind was the
hut river province in western australia
which was an area of land
in western australia
that fellow callings of prince rupert
took over and he issued his own stamps
and banknotes and seceded from the
commonwealth probably not legally
and in fact the lawyer who had
been helping him to arrange all
that business was in contact with a
lawyer john accidents in the uk in listen
or who. Who we got in contact with
and he was a lawyer for carolinian so we
were thinking along those sorts of lines
it was going to be totally self-sufficient
high tech new age. Sort of place.
And when that scale of the new
the new world didn't work.
Many of us came back to what the others
who left the cities were doing weren't
prepared to go back to the city but we
came to nimbin or balance in places like
that where where it was
more people intensive and.
Where there was already and new
culture and plenty of music
and plenty of company and. New school
through our children and so on.
That became important as we
were getting slightly older
and we were starting to have kids and
kids were getting to school age.
So i left cairo in your
eventually in came to nimbin
and was involved in setting
up an image community school.
Just at the time a daughter
was turning five. That was.
Yeah the community school was
it was set up basically by.
John gagan dharti smith there were two
schoolteachers who had worked mainly in.
Independent schools before. John it.
Karen baena in north sydney.
And it was a school which was taught
completely by parents parents all each anyone
who had their children they had to do a
day a week at the school whether it was
taken into kids swimming or
teaching something in particular or
or maintaining the building or
whatever. In a couple of people.
John and dorothy and myself
did about three days a week.
They just just because we wanted to
we got grants straight away from the
commonwealth government
to set up the school
and the grants continued for over the
five or six years that i was there.
We had usually about 50 kids from
about age five to five to 12
just a primary school. And
basically what happens is it is
that the kids were very happy to be there
and thrive there till they
were about 10 years old
when they wanted to go to the real
school and have real teachers
and wear uniforms and took all the
things that we were escaping from.
And it was wonderful.
We had sort of formal classes in the
mornings in the afternoons we played music
and went swimming and went
bushwalking and exploring
and visiting farms in the
back of jeeps and going on.
We went a lot of excursions all around
the country to join our own caves
or to the fraser island
when we used to just take a
couple of company vans in a jeep
and take our 50 kids and live
self-sufficiently and cook
and so on.
Very strong i think the idea
was a did to continuation of.
Parenting in the school system
up to the age of about 10.
And i think it turned out to be most
appropriate a really good model we of course
thought that we could
keep on doing it until
and go through high school
with our own school
but the kids voted with their feet
and they just they didn't want to be taught
by their parents after they were about
10 and they usually all had a
little bit of trouble and issue.
Three months of travel in transition
to the public school system
and then they after
that they did very well extremely well.
We had the best part of school
probably was the excursions.
As i said where we would not be
worried about insurance and so on.
Like all the other schoolteachers would
be and just take the kids anywhere
that was interesting to their education.
The other aspects were
really really the music
and the festivals the dimensions
of sort of magic and spirituality
and in life which was so much missing in
the city and they were really combined.
Right from the beginning we had things
called healing festivals where we would all
en mass go to someplace by a
river on somebody's property
or in the national park
somewhere and it was.
It was like a festival or a bizarre of.
Of healing techniques and meditation
techniques and dancing in music
and this would be a big blackboard where
anyone who could offer anything in the way
of skills of healing or health
for meditation or celebration.
Would write up. Some time of
the day when that would be on.
So i would start off early in the morning
at sunrise with some kind of meditation
and continue through the day we would
cook community we wash each other's hair
community and that night we'd finish.
Health with them with music in the morning
with every morning we'd have big circles
where one sat in a huge
circle which might cover.
You know a quarter an acre
of land and. We chant and.
Hound.
And then those who felt in need of some
sort of feeling of support would sit in the
middle of the circle and
and then all sorts of things would happen
in the way of new age healing techniques
and singing and meditating and.
Channeling energy and so on and so on.
So they were the healing vessels which you
probably have no four five times a year
every full moon we had moon dances because
the power of the moon is so strong in
the country. That you
just need to dance to.
To get the devil there they haven't
celebrate your energy every every time it's
full moon and in between
there were a couple times
that there was a folk
club every every monday.
Where people played folk music
but it was all us doing all these things
to each other with we shampooing each
other's hair or playing music to one another
or building each other's houses of.
Celebrating dancing cooking washing.
It was just wonderful to
suddenly be part of a tribe
and suddenly away from eventually away
from the stifling sort of nuclear families
of the the 50s
and early 60s.
Very very much. It was an adventure
and it was fun. And someone.
People were often asking
what are hippies about
and we always said hippies have found. It
was a really colourful celebrate tree.
Creative adventure.
And when i get an imminent days
and i see what other people
call hippies walking along.
Straight it just isn't the same
breed of human being and so.
It's sort of left over.
Of of a real a real colourful age that i
think is that i think is now past and
and in retrospect i think it was.
Part of a certain age in one's life.
Early in the 20s basically the
years during the 20s when.
When i still think a young person's got no
business jumping straight into the mold
that their parents have left.
And where they should be out exploring
new ways and celebrating their life
and their youth and energy and sexuality
and ability to take drugs without
being too hurt by them and so on
and so on. And it seems very natural for
me and for other people now to have.
As we've got older to gradually go back
into the world into the hopefully have a
bit of a dimension of magic
and spirituality in what we do in our
everyday life as a result of having spent 10
years being out of the
mainstream of society and.
Being able to celebrate and be in touch
with our energy and creativity and.
Just adventures sense of adventure.
I suppose in other generations people
have had new countries to explore.
We had the inside of our minds to explore
and all sorts of possibilities
a relationship.
That we just stifled in the in a
very comfortable way that people
that our parents were
living in in the cities.
If you would be that. I mean.
What's happened to me in the last.
Let's see the last 15 years 10 15
years is that after living on four
or five different communes i
bought my own piece of property.
I bought this property
because it was lovely and.
Had some remnants of rainforest
on but it was mainly grass and.
The farmer next door came over and talked
me into into having some cattle on it
and showed me how to how to do it
and now the property breeds
hereford cattle which.
Half of which eventually you can't get eaten
is meat though people including myself
and.
And now i'm a psychologist in private
practice doing medico legal assessments of
the system
and probably four fifths of my former
friends have also gone back to
back into the world. I call it.
In positions of authority and
responsibility and so on.
Positions where i can offer direction
and guidance and an example to.
Two people. None of us who've done that a
really horrified by what's happened and.
And we look back on our 10
years or so of being hippies
and had of having led the system with.
With thinking that we
would never have not done
that it was a wonderful thing to do
a wonderful time of our lives and
that seemed to be the right thing
to do at that stage of our lives
and this thing this seems to be the right
thing to do now there are a couple of
people who perhaps from our
point of view haven't made
that transition still sort of fighting
it out on the streets of niman but
but they don't have an audience any more.
In my mind it just isn't
happening anymore.
A lot of the things that we thought
we knew and were fighting for now be.
I'm part of the mainstream of society
and of course that's a good thing.
But i'm i'm waiting now for
my. My daughter's generation.
To find find some way of really questioning
what's going on with this crazy
economic rationalism and absence of
jobs and opinions on jobs in the room
and gloom of the present age
and wondering why they are finding some
new territory of of the world of the
mind to start exploring in ways that
that we didn't i think we've done our
are exploring and had our age of doing
that and i'm more than happy to
be to be back in the world now.
I think much strengthened
and and broadened by by
that experience.
It's hard. I mean i.
My immediate answer to
that is is of course i
often wonder whether
i'm often asked whether we lost we've lost
those of us who have returned gone back
into the world of somehow
ditched their ideals
but my very strong feeling is
that that's just just part of us now.
Some of us still grow our own veggies
but some of the still live community
but not many.
And most of those things which we would
probably take as the is the real external
indicators of what it was to be a
hippie we now don't do anymore but.
All i can think now is that
i feel a real richness and.
That bit of magic in spirituality which i
don't think i would have had by this time
if i'd stayed living in the city in the
mold that my parents generation it's.
It up for us.
I think it had to do with the whole thing
i think it even had to do with sort of
inner exploring through the
use of psychedelic drugs and.
Just meeting new new challenges as something
that was very much a turning inward.
And knowing that there's a whole
richness and magic inside you
that your mind is not just.
Just some sort of capacity to
follow an economic rationalist idea
and work harder
and accumulate things it's a real happiness
sometimes to just be by yourself
which we got from a meditation i say
that meditation something you
can take anywhere with you
and you don't mean the equipment for it
and even still the world is so permeated
with other people trying to sell you
things in order to make life interesting
or make you healthy or make you happy
and once you've been
meditating for a long time.
You know that the best way to be
healthy and happy in and to feel magic
and interest is to simply
sit down and be peaceful
and there's a whole world
inside there to look at.
I think the fact that we came
out of the city at that age.
Means
that we just got a real closeness to nature
which which we wouldn't have had before
and in many cases we've got a love
and a closeness to nature which even some
of the old farmers don't have because we
had that the luxury that
the opportunity there.
The joy of being able to walk around and
look at it. With our mind stimulated with.
Good quality marijuana itself and. While
the old farmers are working hard.
Kind of pretending they're
enjoying very out there
and many of them kind of tend when i retire
to move into town in the brick house
and spend their days in the
arras el club with the walls
and floors covered with carpeted the
artificial lights of poker machines.
You know i look forward to retiring being
able to look at the different lights in
the countryside and maybe learning
to capture them in water colours
and returning in a sense to those lovely
happy days when we had endless time and
and we could see that the.
The world in the mind was
endless and the mysterious
and so on.
And i think that.
A lot of the things
that we came up here specifically to do
like to get away from nuclear families to
get away from monogamy to get
away from private property. And.
And to go tribal and and so
on has really not worked out.
And in some ways it doesn't matter because
they were only in retrospect they were
only kind of symptoms of what was
wrong and how we felt trapped
and how we felt very one dimensional
and in our lives in the city.
You can you can we found out that you
can have a closeness to each other.
Physical closeness of trust a sort of
injured interactive life with each other
without.